[Music]
the race to the moon is back 21st
century style and with a new twist and
we're looking at that as part of our new
series American innovation focusing on
the transformative role of Science and
Technology in our lives in the coming
months two startups one of them
intuitive machines the other astrobotic
will plan to launch the first of what
they hope will be a fleet of lunar
Landers touching down on the surface of
the Moon that feat has only been
achieved by three countries never a
company as our Mark Strassman shows us
the Moon is quickly becoming the next
economic Frontier of space if you can
stick The Landing
when intuitive machines went public in
February
nasdaq's Bell also rang as a reminder
that space is now big business this is
Mission Control it's circular it's
smaller we designed this to be like the
bridge of the Starship Enterprise Steve
Ultimus intends to deliver deliver cargo
to the Moon he's co-founder and CEO of
intuitive machines in Houston we're
delivering scientific payloads
engineering demonstration payloads but
not the humans themselves you believe
the Moon is the next economic Frontier
for space the Moon is certainly that
next step for space exploration it's
within our grasp
let's go get it 10 miles to
nothing American-made has touched lunar
dust since Apollo 17. more than a half
century ago
but NASA intends to return astronauts
there in a program called Artemis and
Ultimus envisions a lunar delivery
Market with major customers like NASA
private companies and scientists this is
it this is the assembly room his
company's building a fleet of lunar
Landers its goal annual launches to
delivery addresses a quarter Million
Miles Away the first called Nova C aims
to carry cargo to the moon's South Pole
later this summer lunar Services that's
about a hundred billion dollar market
and so it was enough for us to say we're
all in if intuitive machines is the
FedEx or UPS of the space delivery
Market think of astrobotic in Pittsburgh
as the DHL which happens to be one of
its partners and customers this is the
Lander John Thornton is astrobotics CEO
he gave us a peek at the company's first
Lander called Peregrine
we watched them attach the final major
piece the propulsion system it's a
little bit of a jigsaw puzzle it's like
a moving van it is a jigsaw puzzle
indeed and we're trying to maximize the
capacity the performance of the vehicle
its first mission will carry 21 payloads
to the lunar surface including this
small student-built Rover for Carnegie
Mellon University and five instruments
for NASA right now NASA is the primary
customer over time we see commercial
coming online in a bigger way and right
now we actually can sell directly to to
Consumers who want to send things to the
surface of the Moon Peregrine can carry
roughly 100 pounds of cargo Griffin its
second Lander much bigger can carry 10
times that delivering this water hunting
NASA rover but remember space is
unforgiving attempting to re-establish
communication with our Lander a Japanese
spacecraft crash landed on the moon in
April in 2019 both Indian and Israeli
lunar missions ended the same way the
Thornton tells his customers delivery is
absolutely positively not guaranteed all
we can promise our customers is we are
putting everything we possibly can into
these missions to make them as as safe
and successful as they can be just land
softly that's the key bouncing doesn't
help anymore if you're bouncing you stay
upright that might be okay but if you
bounce and topple that's still good for
a successful touchdown the lunar's
engine has to perform from behind a
blast wall we washed intuitive machines
conduct a test fire
[Applause]
on descent the main engine needs to fire
for eight straight minutes and Throttle
Down for a soft Landing
wow that was quite impressive yeah NASA
plans to spend 2.6 billion dollars over
the next decade buying delivery services
in all 14 different American companies
are building lunar Landers right now we
have routine regular access to the skies
I think by decades and we'll have
routine regular access to the Moon high
risk High reward for any company
creating space in this emerging market
for CBS mornings Mark Strassman in
Houston